hey everyone my name is Jake I'm here to
give you guys a rundown on Kingdom
management and Kingdom building in
ninokuni - it's not that difficult but
there's a lot to take in and if you
don't do certain things you could be
wasting time money resources and so on
so flea this helps one thing I do want
to point out is that this is an endgame
save however I won't be spoiling any
story stuff and there shouldn't be any
story spoilers in this video however you
might see party members that join later
in the game wandering around the city or
if you don't want to see what a what a
high-end Kingdom looks like then maybe
you should wait on this video but in
terms of story there will be no spoilers
but anyway let's hop on the throne and
get started here alright so the first
thing and probably most important thing
you can do is come back to your Kingdom
regularly now this seems obvious but as
you can see I get money and I get
resources over time however the coffers
can only hold so much so if you don't
come back and withdraw your money then
it won't build up so you want to make
sure to come back I don't know maybe
every ingame hour so I recommend so here
we go I'm gonna take my coffers and I'm
gonna take my store supplies cool so
that's just something you want to do
every hour so one thing I would highly
recommend doing is upgrading your
coffers as soon as you can so basically
you just click on your kingdom and
expand coffers this will allow your
kingdom to hold more more money and more
resources so you don't need to come back
as often and you're moving larger sums
of money
the next thing worth talking about are
the different types of buildings that
you can build in your kingdom so there
are three main ones that I'm going to
talk about I'll talk about the first
I'll talk about buildings that give you
more influence these are things like the
square here for example this serves no
real purpose apart from building up your
influence which you can see in the top
right corner
essentially influence allows you to
build more buildings it allows you to
expand your kingdom that allows you to
upgrade different buildings so it's
something that you definitely it's
definitely important to to managing your
kingdom
however it has no immediate effects the
next kind of building we'll take a look
at our research buildings so these are
things like the evermore spell works the
evermore Outfitters and so on basically
these are buildings as they sound that
allow you to research new things so I
can research new spells new perks new
weapons new armor armor upgrades weapon
upgrades and so on these are also the
buildings that will need a pretty good
staff - if you don't unlock some of the
later research and lastly the buildings
that will fill up most your kingdom our
resource gathering ones and these are
like shops and markets fish markets
lumber yards and so on basically these
buildings would just net you resources
over time
as you probably saw here stores so this
is kind of what they gathered for me so
probably my garden got me the tomato
fresh milk was done at the farm the fur
was probably gathered at the bazaar and
so on so depending on what you staff
what you build will depend on what kind
of store items you will get what kind of
resources you'll be getting so those are
the three types of buildings but
obviously you're gonna want these
buildings staffed with different
citizens there are multiple ways to get
citizens I think the most obvious way is
by completing side quests every time you
get to a new town a new settlement
whatever you will probably see these
little exclamation marks dotted around
the map I would make sure to pick up
every single one of those quests because
you'll be able to know which of these
quests will get you citizens and which
won't I would make it a priority to do
all the quests or at least as many as
you can that will get you new citizens
because new citizens are the lifeblood
of your town they are what keeps things
running they're what they're what gets
you money supplies they're what allows
you to research things so that should
take top priority you can also get
citizens by completing story missions
and by completing tasks from Swift
solutions we'll go into that a little
bit later however right now let's look
at some of these buildings so as you can
see I have this staff - the citizens and
the reason they have the star there is
because that means they're suitable for
this type
of research you want to make sure you
kind of stack your citizens in ways that
are suitable for them and for you so if
you can see I can bring up personnel I
can assign a citizen and I have all my
characters pretty much all my characters
that are suitable here because they are
the most efficient and they have the
highest rating on the side another thing
to point out with citizens is that they
do level up as you play the game and as
they complete different tasks however it
may be hard to see that so what you want
to make sure to do is occasionally hop
in your citizens tab here and whenever
you see these blue arrows pointing up
that means they're good for a level up
so there we go I'll level her up and
basically just improve some of their
skills you you don't really have to do
anything on your end except this so
every now and then definitely make sure
to check this because it they will
become more efficient they will learn
you more money their IQ will be improved
and so on so that is that is very
important I'd say now that I have these
buildings staffed with some citizens the
next thing I would want to do his
research so clearly I can go to research
decide what I want to research today and
they will start researching in real time
it usually takes around an hour so so
you can go explore do some missions
whatever while they do that and then you
want to return and complete the research
as you can see this one is almost there
not quite and once that's done you can
start another one I would recommend
having as much research going on as
possible because that is one of the ways
you can improve and you can unlock new
skills abilities new weapons armor and
so on and since all in real time you
might as well just do it while you're
exploring anyway like you can have five
or six research projects going on at
once while you're out completing quests
doing the story whatever it may be so
just make sense to keep that rolling and
the next thing I want to talk about is
what you should prioritize to be honest
it's tough to say it kind of depends on
your play style however I found the most
important things that you should be
upgrading and focusing on are the
evermore spell works the evermore
Outfitters the ever more weapons
workshop and the ever and the Hitler II
basically the most important one in my
opinion is the evermore spell works
because this will allow you to unlock
new spells and level up current spells
so if you want like really cool flashy
spells like fire storms and
thunderstorms and stuff like that this
is where you want to start with at least
for me that's what I that's what I
started with because I like those flashy
spells another really important one is
the weapons workshop even if you don't
typically use it like you get weapons
it's such a quick and constant rate in
this game that I rarely ever went here
to purchase or build a new weapon but
near the end of the game you will need a
evermore weapon workshop level 4 and if
you don't have that you will be gated so
it's just something that you should be
checking up on every now and then if you
want to save yourself some time later in
the game and then there's the Hitler II
which allows you to brew new higgledy 's
and upgrade the current ones you have
this probably isn't super important but
I found the higgledy s to do a lot of
damage especially later in the game so I
came back here kind of frequently to
make sure they were all in tip-top shape
and they're pretty easy to level up you
just need a certain kind of item and
then I think the next most important
thing that I wish you didn't neglect as
much is the general store as you upgrade
this and as you upgrade different
buildings in your kingdom this will get
new this will get new items new
resources and so on so if there's
something you need in particular you can
always go here and just buy it but I
didn't I didn't level it up at all for
the longest time so I had to like jump
from different shops and explore the
world to try to find the things I need
but now I can just go here and get what
I want so I'd say that is that is quite
important all right so next thing that I
want to do after I after I come back
here and click collect my money and
resources is I want to show you guys
swift solutions because if you need if
you're short on people or if you need if
you need certain people that's always a
good spot to check and I'll show you why
right now all right here we are in gold
PAH one of the first towns you visit and
here is the swift solutions right here
so we'll talk to him
and as you can see in the top right
corner I have tokens of gratitude
basically by completing tasks you earn
tokens of gratitude which you think
which you can then trade in for either
items or new citizens I highly recommend
coming here if there's something you
need like if you need a new army or if
you need someone who's good at the forge
whatever I've unlocked most of them so
far but use a few that I haven't so yeah
I'd always make sure to come back here
and grab some new citizens if you're
short all right I think that just about
wraps it up for a kingdom building and
Kingdom management at least as far as
the basics go there is a lot more to it
however if this doesn't interest you you
can still beat the game without paying
much attention to this or if you get
into it you could easily spend 1015
hours just doing this once you kind of
figure out a foundation I'd recommend
just reading up on all the different
buildings and see what kind of research
they offer and figure out what cut what
fits your play style most are you more
into magic than maybe you should focus
on the evermore spell works do you
really like the Higley DS then
definitely pop on over there and see how
you can upgrade them or what you can do
to improve them just kind of depends on
how you play and if you have any
questions feel free to hit me up on
Twitter at Jacob deck all we're always
happy to help I've spent a lot of time
in this game and there's a lot that I
didn't go over just due to time
constraints and so on so yeah let me
know what you think and thank you guys
for watching
[Music]